Cupcakes are a favorite treat for so many kids and even adults.
And this clever and unusual way to serve them will surely bring a smile to anyone who has one.
I'm Liv Hansen for howdini.com and Betty Crocker Kitchens.
And I'm gonna show you how easy these surprise cupcakes are to make.
You'll need some wafer cones, cupcakes, mini cupcakes, frosting and candy.
So, let's get started.
I'm gonna take my cone and fill it with candy, just about halfway.
So now, remove the cupcake liner.
Take a dollop of frosting...
...and place it on top and spread it evenly.
Then, invert the cupcake into the cone.
Place another dollop of frosting on top of this cupcake.
Then, take a mini cupcake and invert it right on top.
Now, it's time to frost our ice cream cone.
We want it to look like a soft-serve cone.
I'm just gonna cover the entire surface with frosting.
I hold the cone in my hand. I think that's the easiest way.
And once we have it all covered,...
...we'll give it a little texture to imitate the soft-serve look.
So, to do that, I'm just gonna run my spatula around.
The final touch - sprinkles!
And there you have your cupcake cone.
I'm Liv Hansen for howdini.com and Betty Crocker Kitchens.